[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode the
Kos and it's the new year 2020 and I was
gonna start it off with a fantastic bang
I was going to see you see all those
boxes that sent it back right over there
those are 13-inch
DC Direct heroes those are dolls right
now um excuse me
not statues now behind me you see who it
is he's spinning he's on the carousel
that is the Green Lantern Hal Jordan and
I was going to do a whole big DCE blast
out but I decided to after I got to
statue here and I unboxed them and I
looked at him and I was like wow it's
way better than pictures or videos can
never show you up close it's it's it's a
magnificent statue left giving you the
history of
relented the first ring lantern was in
all-american comics I think I was number
16
like 1940 or something like that does
before me oh my sorry I've been a little
bit under the weather and that's why I
care West has been away for a minute and
it was a different character it wasn't
Hal Jordan Hal Jordan is the character
that I grew up with Hal Jordan is the
character that you see behind me the
Green Lantern did you see behind me
that's his alter ego Hal Jordan and he
debuted I think it was in showcase DC
showcase 22 and it was a reimagining of
the character he's a fighter pilot and
it was a downed alien ship and the die
an alien passed on his ring to him now
the mantra and hey yo check this out
I even have a power ring and a mask for
green lanten that's how deep you know
I'm into Greenland and how much I like
the character but also also this is the
13 inch doll that I have and I'm gonna
it'll show pictures of it you know later
yeah you know check it out or whatever
but this is of the green lanten corpse
and that's the intergalactic police that
he's a part of if you're not one green
lanten it's a whole intergalactic police
corpse
like the notebook hopes for Marvel DC
has something very similar so as you can
see here's how Jordan I've been sir is
the guy the alien who crash-landed on
the planet and passed his ring to him
and this is also a light up feature here
which I will talk about more with that
statue but the mantra
the model that they speak about with the
Green Lanterns is in the brightest day
in the blackest night no evil shall
escape my sight let those who worship
evils might beware my power Green
Lantern's light and I always thought
that was poetic
it was prophetic it was when you heard
that and it was all about imagination
and willpower and the stronger his
willpower and the more his imagination
he was able to make different constructs
with his mind there was no limitations
on this character this character is to
me
DC's most powerful character the more
powerful than Superman more powerful
than any character because he portrays
that later on after he becomes the
parallax an evil version of himself that
goes on to do horrific cases inside a DC
Universe but hey I'm I'm getting too far
ahead so I want to Statue on eBay and
you know how it goes with eBay either
win something you lose some and this is
the exclusive version what makes this
different than the regular version is
the fact that the exclusive version
comes with the light implanted why would
you want to statute without the light-up
Lantern is beyond me but how Jordan is
definitely the best Green Lantern there
is i am so absolutely happy to have this
statue and right now i'm gonna go into
the details that makes this statue of
most important to me well when you start
to the base the base looks like he's
standing on some type of metal I don't
know a construct but it seems like he's
made of propeller wings out of it out of
his uh his Green Lantern's power which
is amazing then you go to his boots
which will look like if you you know
flying around the galaxy and you got to
go to different planets you will have
these kind of space boots and the black
looks like a matte black the green isn't
overpowering but it has a shimmery
fluorescent type of material look to it
looks kind of metallic to it and it's
just very done the white isn't a
straight white it's uh it has
um different aspects to it you know it's
it's a little bit more than just plain
white and we also have the mass the
portrait on this character is phenomenal
I love it to death I think this is one
of the strongest portraits shy sideshow
has put together we're definitely I'm
definitely happy
and anybody who's definitely got the
statue is happy to have this in their
collection I can't wait to see him side
by side with the rest of my Justice
League I was just looking at Superman
now and can't wait for him to join you
know Superman and Wonder Woman and
Batman because he's a founding member of
the Justice League so this is a part of
the video that I'm gonna tell you to
like follow subscribe also go to Lords
of gaming dotnet we have a ton of
articles reviews from a hard game hard
gaming uh conqueror himself Lord addict
and we have more stuff from Kos also we
have combat talk with the King the last
word with low Cognito and ebon tests
talking all your ludus shooter news and
a ton of opinion pieces and fact
articles by the great mods he's there as
well so see you next week when i bring
you a custom statue and this guy isn't
under the weather as much so a little
sick right now but hey still gotta keep
it push it also hit that joint button
because we go into packs and you want to
see all those great videos that we're
gonna put up in the background take care
and always stay collecting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]